M: Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to Factorio with Bob! Say Hi Bob.
B: Hi!
Mark: Hello! It's been a long time since we did a collaborative effort like this.
B: Especially since we did one where I had to know things and/or be good at things
M: Well, I-I guess that's true because in 'Don't Starve' neither of us knew things
and neither of us did things well so....
Mark: This kind of is a new beginning. Bob: Well we didn't have to so it was - it was fun Mark: Did we? D-Did we not have to though?
Because there might have been some complaints here in there about our lack of performance and uh...
B: I seem to recall it going 'perfectly' so...
M: It went perfectly when we cheated *mark side T-bos*
M: I mean.. B: *laughing*
M: When the good graces of the heavens doth descended upon us
M: But that was besides the point. So anyway, this is Factorio
M: If you guys have watched my videos on this, you know that I love this game.
M: And Bob is now introduced to the fact that..
B: It's so awesome!
M: It's so cool!
B: Look I can ride the conveyor belt! Look--look!
M: Yeah okay! B: Look I'm doing it! M: That's not what I would have called the awesome part of it
M: But good for you!
B: That's the part that I got really worked up about I don't, I don't know what you're talking about.
M: Prolly nothing. But anyway, I'm placing-
M: Oh, there! Military finished
M: So now we can craft not only better guns, but I'm placing turrets around the base to defend us.
B: Yeaaah--
M: Yeeah..  so I'm gonna do actually dedicate one of these just
to making bullets for the turrets
B: Oh yeah, these things need ammo, ok.
M: Yeah, so you can either craft up ammo by
yourself but why do that when you can make assembly machines do it for you!
Bob, this is about where-- the point where you-- I caught you up to this point in the game-
B: I don't know what happens next even at all.
M: Yeah, so what we researched so far is about where we left off in the last episode.
We just have automation, military's done, we have turrets, and the next step is
getting logistics, so I'm gonna get that under way because logistics is
gonna get us fast inserters, which actually move a lot faster than these
slowass burner inserters and... Actually I don't know where I left off with them because
I was playing so much on my own
that I actually am uncertain where they
are... Anyway, we'll just base it off what you know, Bob.
So, these automators where-- where I
said before are gleaning science so we
put copper-
Bob: SCIENCE!--
(Markinerd engage)"Yes, exactly." So I will make another Automator- nope I won't because
because I don't have the materials do that--
Bob: I'll just make a whole assload of gears. I can do that.
M: Yeah, you make gears, and you shove 'em inside of the assembly machine--
B: Shhhhh--Shove 'em in there!-
M: yeah, shove 'em in there right near good.
B: We're Sciencing the shit out of this! Nehaaaaegh?
M: So that's--that's gonna make science and the next thing that we're going to do is we're going to
replace all of our drills, and this is where the overall comes, with power drills.
B: Indeed.
M: Yes, so if you look in the production tab there are electric mining
drills right next to the burner mining
drills. So make as many of those as you can.
B: I can make 0 of those.
M: Ok, get the materials you need to make those.
B: Uhh, catching up, I'm still catching up, I'm working on it.
M: Ah, he's learnin'. And everyone out there is learnin'-
B: I, I just wanna say, I'm not clueless. I set up all of this copper mining stuff while I was doing all this
look at all this set up, also while I
accomplished that little tiny amount of
work, Mark set up all of the rest of this.
M: That's ok, and I- don't forget Stony! Stony up in the corner!
B: Oh yeah Stony, good ol' Stony man.
M: Good ol' Stony here, he's uh, he's only got
literally four conveyor belts to put his
stuff on but he's proud of what he does.
M: He's a good boy.
B: Alright, so I can make three of those
things so I'm making three of those things that
need to make some power poles to go with it right?
M: Yes, exactly and you need some wood,
sticks, yeah.
B: I can make 32 electric power poles. M: Ok, that's good. I'm gonna get the bullets out of this to fill
the turrets because I have a funny feeling-
B: I filled this one over here with some already
M: Oh cool, that's good.
B: I uh, I forgot to fill the other one. Where are the turrets?
There's one there. Is there two turrets, or three turrets?
M: Yeah, I put-I put three turrets generally in like a triangular formation
they should be able to protect us. We
don't know where the aliens are coming
gonna come from first, like in the last
episode I definitely know that you guys
did not see an alien attack and we're
actually started on a different map
before this when we got fuuucked in the ass by these-
B: Oh yeah it was so awesome, so awesome.
M: Well we had to restart because the
resources weren't in line with everything else so we were just so boned
by not having what we needed, but uh now-
B: Omg these electric drills are fucking enormous!
M: Yes! And they work waaay better, like so much better.
B: Alright. So I'm going to deconstruct two of my steam- or my burny
ones over here, give it the ol' electric drill situation.
M: That's good, I like it.
B: And where the fuck does he poop out the iron ore? I can't even tell.
M: You zoom in, you can see
the chute is about the same looking as the other ones.
B: I don't.. I think it's right there.
M: Yeah, it's-it's the orange thing, or the copper-looking thing at the top.
B: Ok, yeah, ok. Then I just need to place
like poles to connect up with your electric grid right?
M: Yes, exactly. And you kind
of want to space them out gent- nicely
because it can get- pretty late into the
game, it just gets really sporadic where you put these things. So just try to keep
it organized, but then just understand
the chaos is going to ensue eventually. So
for those of you out there who don't know, we're hooking up electricity to our
mining drills, Bob is putting an electric
mining dig thing over there. He's gonna
make more poles and then connect that. I just connected the copper one to that one so
the copper's chuggin' out very quickly
and very rapidly, and then everything
else is gonna go wonderfully and nothing will go wrong!
Hopefully.
M: ... Bob?
B: Uh yeah, definitely.
M: Is nothing gonna go wrong?
B: Yeah no, it's fine it's probably fine, it's prolly fine.
M: Oh, I don't like the 'probably' that you're puttin' out here.
B: Alright! I- Hey, I set up an electric mining thing! Look at that!
M: Yay! Good job Bob!
B: I did it!
M: Ok, the only thing with that is now the copper from the electric one is poppin' out
on the wrong side of the tracks.
B: No, it's been like that the whole time I've-
M: Oh, nevermind then.
B: It's fine, don't worry about it.
M: Ok! I'm not worried about it!
B: It makes this copper
just the same so it uh, I did not attempt to fix that.
M: Ok good enough, I-I believe you.
B: You believe I made no attempt to fix it? That's not good..
M: That's just what I expect out of our dynamic, just-
B: Eh that's about right for Bob. You know what? Good effort.
M: Good-good attempted try.
B: Excellent try. Ok, I'll fix it later, don't worry.
M: Yeah. Okay I'm just gonna put the last new drill will go in the iron area, and
then that should be golden for what we're trying to do later. So the next
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
string these up.
AH! I'm out, I'm outta poles.
B: I got more poles, you need more poles?
M: Nah, I'm making more poles, they're easy to make but the next thing
I'm doing a string of this up over here
because eventually we're gonna replace
all of the inserters with electric
inserters which are faster and more
efficient than burner inserters.
B: So, is two.. how, how do electric mining rigs compare
to the burner mining rigs? Am I, are they, I've got two where I had four previously
is that gonna keep up? Or is that not really gonna keep up?
M: I think it's about one
electric is worth three burners? Or maybe two burners. One's worth two burners.
So they, they work really well.
B: They do seem to be pretty efficient. I've got another
electric drill I could put up, do you want me to put it on the coal and get rid of these other burners?
M: Yeah, go ahead. Do it up.
Do as many as you can because there's
literally no limit to what we can do in
terms of electricity, we just need to keep providing more and
more power to it.
B: I thought you were gonna say there's no limit to what we can imagine.
M: Well, let's not go that far. There's definitely a limit to what we can imagine and I'm trying to-
B: I imagine all kinds of stuff! Look, this is a dick and balls! Look at how I imagine that!
M: I-I don't know! Wow! I never even thought
of that before!
B: I've never imagined things like that before, so-
M: You've never imagined dick and balls?
B: Oh doh, so no. Or whatever sounds most convincing. Alright, so how do I make electric
gravity goos? Iron, oh i just need iron and I can make 'em.
M: Yeah, exactly. they literally just take copper and iron
and you stick those together and then you put 'em in and ram them together as fast as you can...
B: Just fuck 'em
in there, just put 'em right in there.
M: Just fuck 'em in there.
M: I've never- I've-
B: -father.
M: Fuck your father, fuck your father..
B: Fuck your father...
M: I've never heard something described just 'Fuck it right in there', so that's new.
Is that your slogan for your channel?
B: 'Hey bobbleheads! Fuck it right in there.'
Don't worry about it, just fuck it right in there.
M: It'll take care of itself, just fuck it on right in there, it'll be fine.. I'm just
extending the burner operation because
we're eventually going to need a lot
more stuff and now I can start replacing it with electric inserters.
B: Those are some really inefficient poles
and perhaps I should change them later
but for now, whatever. Fuck it. Just don't look at my elec-
Look at your fucking electric poles and look at my shit.
M: I literally had not looked down until then, and just kinda like-
B: I was just ike 'Ah! Where's it gonna fit? Ah, get in there! Oh no!'
M: And just generally like,
your whole area kinda describes it like, your- the simplest thing is you could have had your
electric drills in line with each other, but no,
let's just put them one block off to make it infuriating.
B: I was basing them on the burner drills that I had
which were also are already fucked so it's like, eh, who cares?
M: Oh my god, three of the four inserters are on the same side of the burner, and
this last fucker is-
B: It's so that it's on the electric grid, ok? It's not a very well-planned out thing!
Just chill your fucking tits!
M: Ok, alright, you know it's fine.
It's generally acceptable, I-
B: Is it functioning at the same capacity as it would be if
it was more logically constructed? That's the question.
M: Yes, you're right, it is.
B: So, it's perfect is what you're saying.
M: Yes, it's perfect to your perfect, what you do could be described as perfection.
B: That's very generous of you say that out loud.
M: Yeah, now that I said it out loud I kinda
regret saying it so-
B: You feel bad about it a little bit-
M: -a little bit, I'm gonna take it back if you don't mind, just-
B: That's- I, totally expected that, so. It's fine.
M: I'm gonna make more electric- eventually I'm just gonna replace all of these-
B: Yeah, I'm all electric over here, baby.
M: Oh geez.
B: Oh, no I'm not. Fuck. Don't. Damn. Don't look! M: Wait, I'm gonna look! B: Hang on! Nononono!
M: I'm looking!
B: Look, there's no non-electric stuff down here. That one is totally powered.
B: Just don't look! For god's sake!
M: I'm not looking, man!
B: Just to make, just to make you happy,
Look what I'm gonna do. I'm gonna put this guy where he belongs, so that these are all inter-symmetrical.
M: Wow! It's so symmetrical! It looks so much better now, except for the powerlines!
B: Yeah, just ignore the powerlines!
They look like they were drawn on by an 8 year old!
M: I mean, effectively they were, if we're considering all things, bu-
B: It's like your area was designed by like a city planner, and my area was designed by guys in the
15th century who did not know electricity was gonna be such a big deal.
Like, 'Oh fuck! We didn't leave any places for power poles, I don't know!'
M: Yeah, when electricity was first around, they were like 'This is a fad! It's not gonna catch on!
*pfft* This is bullshit!'
B: 'What even IS electricity? I don't understand!'
B: You know what, I'm gonna make myself useful and I'm gonna make
sure that we're still producing ammo and- oh, we're out of copper. Oh no, you just need iron for that.
I'm gonna go around and reload all the turrets-
M: Thank you!
B: -put more in them or whatever.
M: You da best.
You da bestest there ever was. I'm gonna- I actually need to make more boilers for
the steam engine.
B: Do we have plenty of Science going on now, or-
M: We do not, actually.
M: I totally forgot about that-
B: I need to make some more gears. So we should make another assembly plant where it producing gears, right?
M: Yes! Absolutely!
B: Alright, I'm gonna make an assembling machine.
M: Mhm? Yeah? I like this?
B: Alright? And then I'm gonna place it-
Hang on.
M: Cool, ok. Take your time! The gears are turnin'. It's ok!
B: You can feel it, right? It's gonna happen.
M: I can feel it!
B: Oh, your power pole's in the way, man. It's fucking me up.
M: Oh, I'm sorry.
M: Move it then!
B: How far can these reachy things reach?
M: Ah, it can reach pretty-pretty far.
B: So if I go like, that-
B: And- I'm gonna go like-
M: Oh, it's so ugly.
B: Shut up!
B: I'M THINKING!
M: Okay!
B: And I go like that, and then- No! Not that.
B: And then we go, and then, you're gonna make-
*Crash in the background*
M: Whoa!
B: Oh gosh, is- that's not, that's a burner one, not an
electric one. Alright, how do I get my electric
ones out?
M: Uhh... good question.
B: Oh god.
M: Uhhhh... Boink! Ok!
B: Ah, shit!
M: Oh wow, that this is PUMPIN'.
M: Ok, is that enough power- If you want to know a cool thing, if you click on...
M: The...
B: Mark, that's not working.
M: What's not working?
B: Oh wait, I got it.
M: There it goes! Now it's working!
M: But if you'da made it one step up,
you could've had the gear grabber inserted into the science machine.
B: What?
M: Okay, if you'd have moved this assembly machine one notch up, you could have another, uh,
inserter right here, running it right into the science machine. B: Ohhhh
B: I gotcha.
B: I gotcha...
M: The inserter's just like, 'Wh-what? Wh-where'd it go?'
B: NOW I got it.
NOW we're working with gasoline and stuff.
M: Okay, power's gonna go out real quick,
don't mind the thing, everything's fine. I just need to make another, another few steam engines.
Don't mind it, it's-it's fine. Everything's fine.
B: It seems fine.
M: Everything is fine. Why would you ask if everything is fine?
B: Definitely seems fine.
M: It's definitely fine.
M: There's no question about that.
B: Wait, so is this what you had in mind? Or...
M: Ummm.. yes! That is exactly what I had in mind.
B: Nailed it.
M: Nnnice.
B: I am a genius.
M: NICE
M: Ok! So that- if you-
Actually, handy dandy tip: if you left-click on an electric pole,
you can actually see the production and
demand in live.
And we were actually not meeting production needs
because all of these were not pumping out nearly enough power.
We need a lot more power.
B: Hm.
M: *inhale*
M: Sooo...
M: I'm going to make one more dodaddie...
M: Oh shit, oh, I coulda made this such better- design-
I could've made this- I can actually redo this, because it's gonna make me mad
if I don't redo this, but oddly enough we're all out of time for this episode.
So! We're gonna keep playing this-
thank you Bob so much for joining me.
Check out Bob's channel in the description.
His channel name is Muyskerm, in case you didn't know by his user name.
Wait, what is my name in this game? I forgot.
B: Bumbles
M:Bum- Bumbles!
M: Okay! So, see you from Muyskerm and Bumbles.
So, THANK YOU everybody so much for watching
and as always,
we'll see YOU
in the next video! Buh-bye!
[Outro music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]